alain vidalies sts ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec l' agence france-presse
et dailymotion est avec nous tout à
l'heure car ils paieraient de la sp et
puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat
monsieur le ministre les chiffres du
chômage viennent de tomber en il
s'apparente à un supplice chinois
supplémentaire j'ai envie de dire pour
l'exécutif dans cet entre deux tours des
élections municipales avec une forte
hausse au mois de février plus 31500
demandeurs d'emploi une première
réaction c'est une augmentation marquée
31500 en catégorie a qui peut être
légèrement atténué si on regarde sur
l'ensemble des catégories à b et c c'est
à dire les demandeurs d'emploi qui n'ont
pas exercé une activité à plein temps
sur moi ou sur trois mois on est à 7500
pour pour cela je pense que il faut
regarder ces chiffres avec trois
indicateurs qui sont publiés aujourd'hui
la première indicateur c'est celui d'
activités économiques là les chiffres du
chômage c'est ceux du mois de mars
l'indicateur de l'activité économique
c'est le chômage pardon c'est du mois de
février l'indicateur économique c'est
celui du mois de mars par wick ça repart
un peu même bien puisque c'est la
première fois depuis 31 mars paraît trop
technique mais l'indicateur à partir
quand on est au dessus de 50 ça veut
dire que la croissance repart on se
situer ces dernières années où depuis
ces derniers mois depuis 31 mois autour
de 47 48 51 3 ces deux étudiants et la
deuxième raison elle est aujourd'hui
dans la presse ce matin je prends la
presse économique travaille l'écart se
réduit avec l'allemagne c'est pas le
résultat du hasard il suffit de regarder
à l'intérieur de cet article mais tu
expliquer que c'est la conséquence du
la mise en place du cicr par le
gouvernement pourquoi j ça parce qu'il
faut regarder et répondre à la question
qu'est ce que vous faites par rapport au
problème du chômage si vous regarder
dans le détail des chiffres qui vont
être qui viennent d'être plein d'anciens
cadres dans le détail mais il faut quand
même qu'on retienne le chiffre essentiel
ne sait plus de 30000 freezer ils sont
31 ans parce que les enfants des
catégories ya ce sont des drames de
savoir qui c'est et ça mérite
un peu plus de précisions je voulais
dénoncer pas celle là
avant les donne aux ami jamie tchèque à
la réflexion là dessus le chômage des
jeunes augmente très peu 1500 de plus
mais sur neuf mois il recule il y à
aujourd'hui en france un problème très
particulier qui l'a explose dans les
statistiques y compris ce mois ci c'est
les plus de 50 ans c'est à dire qu'on
est dans la situation aujourd'hui ou sur
un an qui est une bonne période de
réflexion
on a un chômage qui augmente pour qui
pour les jeunes de moins de 20 ans
diminue de 1,5 pour cent mais qui pour
les plus de 50 ans et à +12 virgules
alors pour ça c'est vrai depuis
plusieurs mois vous envisager des
mesures spécifiques pour les seniors je
pense que la question est posée
aujourd'hui à la fois de la réalité de
cette statistique là et qui entraîne en
plus une divergence avec les chiffres du
bureau international du travail
alors donc il faut qu'on regarde ça de
près mais je pense que cette réalité là
elle mérite d'être précisée parce que
les gens nous demandent d'apporter des
réponses et on voit bien aujourd'hui
qu'on est confronté à une exclusion du
marché du travail les plus de 50 ans une
progression marquée un de ceux de nombre
de chômage en france
vous le reconnaissez évidemment je le
disais ce sont à chaque fois des
souffrances individuelles pour les
familles mais ça va encore peser plus
lourd dimanche prochain dans les urnes
il nous faut la transparence dans la
situation économique cde pas caché les
chiffres cessé de les donner
même si c'est la réalité d'aujourd'hui
et vous savez ce que nous demande le
sens me till les concitoyens c'est
qu'est ce que vous faites quel est votre
réponse il y en a d'autres que possible
n'y a pas qu'une seule politique mais la
nôtre et les clairs on l'a engagé c'est
pour ça que j'ai parlé de l'activité
économique et j'ai parlé de l'article
des échos ce matin sur le différentiel
du coût du travail avec l'allemagne
c'est soit le résultat du hasard c'est
le résultat de la politique qu'on a mis
en oeuvre et je préfère si vous voulez
avoir un indicateur économique préfère
mettre en avant les éléments positifs on
le comprend enfin l'inversé gestion pour
bien sûr
vous pouvez le faire vous même sur les
éléments négatifs c'est aussi votre
travail mais je pense qu'il ya un
ensemble de choses que je voulais finir
ma france et il vaut mieux avoir un
indicateur d'activité économique pour le
mois de mars c'est à dire pour
aujourd'hui
qu'ils soient bons pour que l'espoir que
l' inverse alors positif négatif dit moi
le climat ce mercredi matin aux
conseillers des ministres il ne veut pas
être positif très honnêtement il était
assez assez ordinaire j'ai pas si
quelqu'un avance de l'état est intervenu
ce corps social et le premier tour des
mines lointain quel était son message le
message du chef de l'état il a été très
clair il a dit dès lors qu'il ya une
élection où il faut tirer les
conséquences
entendre ce qu'on dit les français qu'on
voter at il ajouté y compris entendre
ceux qui ne sont pas venus voter il faut
prendre son expression dans sa globalité
et donc il a dit il faut préparer le
second tour puisque c'est le
rassemblement qui doit qui doit
l'emporter explique et encore plus si
c'est nécessaire
ce qu'on a fait mais naturellement il
faudra en tirer les conséquences et
réveiller les abstentionnistes de gauche
qui effectivement ont fait défaut oui ce
que toujours un peu le cas par rapport
au parti qui est au pouvoir si on fait
la comparaison avec avec 2008 mais il ya
aussi un message qui est assez simple
c'est que peut penser dans tous les cas
c'est ce qu'on nous dit qu'un certain
nombre de personnes ne sont pas venus
voter parce que les résultats ne sont
pas au rendez vous que la politique
sociale leur leur déplaît donc ce
raisonnement là il est valable au
premier tour puisqu'il n'y en a pas
beaucoup de conséquences au second tour
l'idée de s'abstenir pour faire élire la
droite qui pour le coup personne ne va
prétendre que sur le plan social c'est
là qu'on va trouver des solutions
j'attire l'attention de chacun je prends
un seul exemple on a eu des débats à
l'assemblée nationale ont peu le pas
être d'accord avec la réforme des
retraites qui a été fait par ce
gouvernement mais enfin quand on ajoute
la pénibilité que nous on maintient à
l'accès à 62 ans de l'âge de la retraite
et enfin ce à quoi on a une droite qui
dit non c'est c'est 65 ans là on a signé
hier le décret qui pour les personnes
qui travaillent à temps partiel permet
de valider un trimestre à part
250 heures vous dit tout ça ce sont des
choses qui doivent être président à
votre secteur va ça va on a bien compris
on a reçu la gifle c'est pas la peine de
nous en remettre une deuxième dimanche
cinq couleurs dites tête une image mais
on peut résumer comme ça on peut la
résumer comme ça selon bruno le roux le
patron des députés ps françois hollande
estime que cette gifle du premier tour
est une forme d'injustice
c'est une forme d'injustice pour vous
savez les électeurs sont jamais sont
jamais injuste à les électeurs bien sûr
que nous sommes ne paraît pas effective
est juste pour les autres tenue de super
sortant et qui ont subi le contrôle et
la politique c'est normal ils ont
toujours ce sentiment là mais enfin
quand on a un engagement politique il
vaut pout rivaux pour sa globalité
donc si tu peux y avoir ici ou là un
sentiment un sentiment d'injustice mais
suffrage universel n'est jamais n'ai
jamais refusé un gouvernement qui n'est
pas professionnel pas suffisamment
professionnel c'est harlem désir qu'il
dit que presse que vous réagissez à
écouter ce qu'il a comme qualité de
grand témoin pour pour projet de ça on
peut toujours s'améliorer il faut avoir
beaucoup d'humilité dans la façon dont
on dirige les affaires de l'état et de
ce point de vue là pas l'intention de
donner des leçons à qui que ce soit
ce que je veux dire quand même parce que
je suis témoin je suis en relation avec
tous les ministres est souvent compte
tenu de ma fonction c'est franchement
tout ce travail beaucoup sont très
engagés sur leurs ministères le font
avec conviction donc là il ya une
fantastique vous le dites il ya une
appréciation mais je prends ça comme un
encouragement dès que le héros bashing
amplifiée par des vous des ténors même
du parti socialiste il vous choque
quel ténor robin on peut un peu quand
même
alors je sais que je vais vous avez vous
un ténor c'est votre appréciation c'est
pas la mienne mais on a entendu jean
glavany aussi par exemple ça a été un
intérêt on a entendu bertrand delanoë
parler d'une claque pour le gouvernement
c'est elle était différent ils mettaient
pas en cause les reçoit directement je
préfère l'appréciation qui est fait en
général et qui juste de la sq est pas
supportable c'est les attaques
personnelles pour
dire attaqué attaqué un homme on a mené
cette politique le président la
république a été élu sur une ligne
politique on a mené cette politique avec
un premier ministre qui jamais n'a
failli à sa tâche à la solidarité qui
toujours a été pour essayer de dégager
des consensus a vait les groupes
parlementaires qui a été très présent
dans le dialogue
moi je trouve que peut y avoir des
décisions qui ne relèvent pas évidemment
de l'appréciation des ministres mais
uniquement du président de la république
mais ça ne justifie sa peut se justifier
pour des raisons politiques pas pour des
raisons à personne alors on se dit que
l'impulsion même le choc nécessaire
passe par un changement de tête à
matignon
ça c'est votre appréciation est-ce
qu'elle sera partagée par le président
de la république je ne sais pas savez ce
n'est pas une règle absolue pour
reprendre votre expression la droite a
pris une gifle à peu près comparable en
il me semble qu'au monsieur fillon rs
est premier ministre on le voyait il n'y
a pas de règle absolue il avait même
qu'ils avaient même pris une déjà une
gifle en 2004 et monsieur raffarin était
était était premier ministre alors ceux
qui aujourd'hui vont sur les plateaux en
dix ans il faudrait presque qu'ils
démissionnent avant le 2e temps avant le
deuxième tour peut-être un peu de
sagesse
puisque les sérieux le maintien de jean
marc ayrault à matignon est une
hypothèse crédible
oui c'est une hypothèse crédible le
président de la république n'a pas dit
qu'il allait changer premier ministre il
n'a pas non plus dit qu'il est confirmé
c'est sa décision
mais voilà le héros bashing n'a aucun
fondement il peut y avoir d'autres
raisons qui justifient la décision du
président dans tous les cas c'est lui
appartient à lui celles et tous les
autres commentaires me semble inutile
superflue et à vrai dire parfois et
c'est désagréable par rapport au premier
ministre car en tous les cas il ya un
trio dont on parle c'est manuel valls
laurent fabius claude bartolone qui est
donc des candidats déclarés à matignon
que pensez vous de ces hypothèses on
n'est pas candidat à matignon
donc tous ceux qui pensent être candidat
à matignon ils sont candidats à rien
c'est le président de la république qui
choisit le premier ministre donc les
candidatures ne servent à rien et c'est
le président qui décidera
est-ce que l'entrée au gouvernement de
martine aubry si c'est possible ce
serait un bon signal envoyé aux
électeurs de gauche selon vous alain
vidalies si la réponse est est ce que il
faudrait que évidemment que des
personnalités comme ça tout le monde
souhaite ce qu'elles soient à nos côtés
mais martina aubry a répondu que c'était
pas dans ses projets aujourd'hui qu'elle
est dans la bataille pour la bataille
pour lille à la fois la question est à
la fois la réponse à ségolène royal elle
est candidate elle est pas mal mais je
ne vais pas oui c'est pas de ma
compétence et je n'ai pas à faire ce
casting que j'ai observé et que ça
risque de vous occuper encore pas d'un
certain nombre de jours mais pas plus
gros coup là maintenant apparemment ça
peut aller très vite pensé vous dès le
lendemain ou le surlendemain du second
tour des municipales
mais ça je n'en sais rien je vois que
vous faites des pronostics pour ça fait
longtemps mais il semble que vous
approchez de la vérité voilà voilà
bon ça c'est un point jean pierre
raffarin était à votre place hier pour
ce preuve par trois il a estimé que le
responsable de la montée du front
national c'était le parti socialiste en
raisons de ses échecs que lui répondez
vous je pense qu'il est plus inspiré
d'habitude que là c'est probablement
l'énervement d'avant le second tour qui
le conduit à de telles excentricités sur
le plan intellectuel
la montée du front national elle a aussi
eu lieu sauf havre une mauvaise foi
totale sous les gouvernements de droite
elle obéit à d'autres raisons et puis
sur le plan idéologique c'est pas nous
qui avons fait un ministère de
l'identité nationale c'est pas nous qui
avons essayé avec monsieur buisson de
mener monsieur sarkozy de mener une
campagne pour les élections
présidentielles où on se demander où tel
front national où étaient l'ump avec des
propos qui dépasse et je dirais le cadre
normal de l'expression d'un parti
républicain de droite ça vous inquiète
le fait qu'il y aura plusieurs villes
front national des moucheurs bien sûr
moi je considère que c'est pas un parti
républicain je le dis très clairement
donc je l' ai déjà dit je pense que
c'est un parti démocrate puisqu'il peut
participer aux élections mais je pense
que ces propos la république c'est
l'égalité la liberté la fraternité et la
fraternité
c'est pas l'exclusion d'une partie de la
population c'est pas la stigmatisation
d'une partie de la population et je
pense que ça reste un parti à part parce
que il ne répond pas aux exigences
aujourd'hui de ce que doit être la
république mais vous partager l'opinion
de cécile duflot qui lors du conseil des
ministres ce mercredi matin a expliqué
que l'ampleur du vote front national en
fait traduisait une exaspération sociale
je sais pas si ça peut se résumer cela
je crois que c'est quand même un peu
plus un peu plus compliqué je pense que
c'est une question de peur de dire ce
sur quoi je vous l'extrême droite qui
n'est pas une création des uniquement la
de 2014
il ya eu des périodes de notre histoire
dans lequel des partis de ce type la
populiste honteux pris de l'ampleur et
toujours en surfant sur l'inquiétude des
gens la peur la peur de l'autre ici
c'est quoi c'est la peur de la
mondialisation c'est la peur la perte
d'identité c'est la peur la peur de
l'autre la peur de notre culture la peur
de tout on fait pas une société a
n'ayant peur de tout et en ayant peur
des autres c'est pour ça que ce parti-là
iman complètement dans l'impasse dans la
division en france on peut pas se
rassembler sur des valeurs qui repose
sur l'exclusion alors le message est que
le message du premier tour a été
entendue c'est ce qu'on a compris de vos
propos jusqu'à présent alain vidalis et
on annonce plus de justice sociale alors
sous quelle forme peut-être que vous
allez pouvoir nous le dire maintenant on
devrait pouvoir répondre aux questions
de karine perret de l' agence
france-presse
mais il faut quand même rappeler que
françois hollande a un agenda bien
défini pour les semaines et les mois qui
viennent entre le pacte de
responsabilité et puis également le
programme d'économies budgétaires 50
milliards d'euros sous l'oeil de
bruxelles
les explications tout de suite pas te de
responsabilité plan d'économies de 50
milliards maîtrise des dépenses
publiques
c'était l'après municipal promis par
françois hollande mais comment demander
ses efforts aux français sans en
rajouter dans la colère des électeurs de
gauche
pour certains députés il faut que le
président corrige à nouveau son cap
celui fixé lors de sa conférence de
presse le 14 janvier dernier où la
politique que nous menons n'est pas la
meilleure elle n'est pas équilibrée elle
ne reprend pas suffisamment en compte
les attentes par exemple des ouvriers
des employés
mais voilà le gouvernement subit aussi
la pression de bruxelles et l'agenda est
déjà bien tracé la france placés sous
surveillance renforcée par la commission
européenne n'a plus qu'une année pour
ramener son déficit public à 3 % et elle
doit présenter à bruxelles les détails
de son pacte de stabilité de mois
prochain alors à bercy on annonce les
comptes désastreux pour la france pour
le gouvernement actuel
le débat est donc clos et pour le
ministre michel sapin économiser 50
milliards d'euros de dépenses publiques
c'est l'intérêt supérieur de la france
voilà donc pour ce rappel signé jérôme
au nord avec nous vos questions
plus de justice sociale concrètement
quel geste fiscal pourriez-vous faire je
pense que vous avez fait presque toute
la totalité de la question et de la
réponse le champ peut être effectivement
le champ fiscal mais aucune décision n'a
été prise ça veut dire c'est un peu la
suite d'une réforme qui a été lancé
d'ailleurs par le premier ministre une
réforme de la fiscalité des ménages et à
du travail qui se fait aujourd'hui dont
on ne peut pas donner les conclusions
ça veut dire que cette réforme là reste
d'actualité mais on pourrait annoncer
des mesures ou quelques grandes lignes
avant le deuxième tour pour dire qu'on a
compris le message des urnes dimanche
dernier
oui mais
l'idée c'est d'avoir une déclaration de
politique qui parlera à la fois du pacte
de responsabilité des économies de la
trajectoire des finances celle inverse
de la démagogie jetables un ici dire les
choses c'est le plan c'est la totalité
c'est équilibré ce sera annoncé par le
président de la république et il y aura
une question on va la responsabilité du
gouvernement soient engagées par le
premier temps l'assemblée nazis nous
préciser la nature de l'intervention que
fera le chef de l'état à l'issue du
second tour monsieur je ne sais pas si
son intervention portera de sur le
détail de ce long temps pas mais dans
tous les cas c'est une question de jours
puisque vous l'avez vous même rappelé il
ya une échéance à fin avril à la
trajectoire des finances publiques
vis-à-vis de bruxelles dont chacun sait
qu'il y aura probablement d'ici fin
avril dans tous les cas l'engagement de
responsabilité du gouvernement devant
l'assemblée nationale et que ce moule
cet engagement de responsabilité il se
fera sur le pacte de responsabilité mais
aussi sur l'ensemble la question de
karine c'était avant dimanche
parce que ce matin on entendu au conseil
des ministres avant le bac à sable nous
dire on va pas annoncer entendu ça veut
dire que quand on s'engage à tirer les
conséquences de ce que disent les
électeurs même et une élection ces deux
tours franchement faire des annonces
entre les entre les deux tours ce serait
démagogique vous dites oui enfin très
honnêtement je trouve que ce serait
assez malvenu et dans tous les cas ce
n'est pas la conception de la politique
du président et du prévenu mes questions
on a envie de savoir quand même ce
qu'est ce que vous avez pouvons annoncer
pour les que je viens de vous dire je
vais pas vous annoncer aujourd'hui ce
que ce que le président de la république
et le premier ministre et diront dans
quelques jours naturellement est-ce que
c'était une erreur par exemple de
supprimer les mesures sur la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
c'était un choix on peut en débattre
mais c'était un choix est ce
qu'aujourd'hui
est ce que dans un pays et qui a trois
millions de demandeurs d'emploi c'était
intéressant de dépenser 4 milliards 4
milliards par an pour permettre à ceux
qui avaient déjà un travail de continuer
à faire des enfants la mesure jusqu'à
que vous annoncez pour les foyers
modestes elle coûtera beaucoup plus cher
peut-être 10 milliards d'euros et je
vous parle politique de l'emploi nous
avons fait un transfert de ces sommes là
parce que c'est à peu près le bukut pour
la création de 255 milles la première
année 150 me de cette année sur les
emplois d'avenir pour les jeunes si
aujourd'hui on a une maîtrise une
diminution depuis neuf mois du chômage
des jeunes c'est parce que ce
gouvernement a mené une politique
volontariste largement d'ailleurs
critiqué par la droite mais c'est 150
mille jeunes 110000 aujourd'hui 150
mille demain vous parliez tout à l'heure
avec juste raison de ces nouveaux
chômeurs qui s'y de 30000 qui sont dans
la difficulté mais c'est 150 milles de
là on peut aussi dire en face que ils
ont peut-être retrouver je dirais un peu
d'espoir dans la vie grâce à ce qu'on
ait mis en oeuvre pour la presse second
tour donc françois hollande devrait
s'exprimer d'une façon ou d'une autre
est-ce que plus largement il doit ou est
ce qu'il peut et ce qu'il en a les
moyens vu les contraintes budgétaires
bruxelles changer quelque chose sur le
pack de responsabilité sur le cap qu'il
s'est fixé le 14 janvier j'ai beaucoup
de socialistes le presse de le faire lui
dise il y aura un avant et un après
municipal il faut changer quelque chose
en elles syndicaliste edouard martin qui
le dit aussi
qu'est ce qu'il peut faire je pense que
le problème qui existait avant les
élections municipales il existe toujours
après donc ce problème il est lequel
c'est que aujourd'hui la france un
problème de compétitivité et que la
france a un problème de déficit du
commerce extérieur
il faut bien que comprendre une chose
c'est que on a une sorte de double peine
qui s'applique à nous pourquoi parce que
nos principaux partenaires notamment
l'allemagne et d'ensemble de la zone
euro est positif sur le plan du commerce
extérieur et c'est parce que il c'est
positif que laure haut et fort nous on a
à la fois un déficit important et on
supporte coûte 2 euros
et personne ne peut s'exonérer de cette
difficulté c'est pour ça que je parlais
tout à l'heure de la question du coût du
travail
il faut absolument dans ce pays que l'on
retrouve des éléments de cons
dj t et ceux qui oppose ceux que posent
ces chantant ses discours
ce qui oppose la politique de l'offre
avec la question de la une politique de
la demande c'est-à-dire la relance par
la consommation il peut y avoir un
arbitrage intermédiaires et la question
peut se poser
mais c'est pas une peau une autre
politique ou une politique alternative
parce que personne ne peut s'exonérer de
la question sur la compétitivité et
ensuite ça va être quand on est arrivé
on a trouvé un pays qui avait sur les
dix dernières années perdu 700 mille
emplois industriels
chacun comprend aujourd'hui si vous
remettez si vous relancez la presse que
ça va être donc le statu quo sur ces
questions là c'est pas le seul
vous avez déjà aujourd'hui on l'a vu
j'ai parlé du coût du travail 20
milliards dus ces messieurs qui vont
maintenant rentrer dans la compte dans
les comptes des entreprises pour
favoriser l'investissement les 10
milliards on discute avec les
entreprises vous avez vu au départ il y
avait l'idée est ce qu'il faut d'abord
baissé toutes les cotisations des
allocations familiales ou est-ce qu'on
garde le cic e + 10 milliards est-ce
qu'on voit d'abord sur les bas salaires
ou est ce qu'on voit sur la
compétitivité il ya un vrai débat parce
que si on va sur les bas salaires c'est
plus une mesure emploi ça s'étend
aujourd'hui en train d'être débattue y
compris avec le chef d'entreprise à
gauche vous approcher une partie de la
gauche de faire des cadeaux au patronat
on a même entendu le patron de la cgt
dire le vrai premier ministre
c'est monsieur gattaz est là est ce que
vous allez corrigé donc le pack de
voyage
est-ce que vous allez réorienter ajouté
je ne sais pas un volet social ou
environnemental opaques les radios les
cadeaux au patronat
ça serait sur le plan fiscal quand on
donne aux entreprises la possibilité
d'investir comme des investissements ça
veut dire qu'il ya des salariés derrière
c'est enfin en fait on n l'entreprise
c'est une entreprise c'est pas que les
patrons c'est aussi c'est aussi les
salariés et donc je pense que c'est une
une vision qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
acceptable
nous sommes obligés d'avoir une
politique d'investissement le volet
contrepartie à ce pacte de
responsabilité ce qui sera plus
important sur le plan social sur le plan
écologique comme le réclament les
écologistes qui sont qui sont sur les
rangs 106 sur la transition sur la
transition écologique vous savez que
c'est un c'est un engagement pris par le
président de la république c'est une
texte de loi qui va venir devant le
parlement
je peux vous dire à l'automne et
j'ajoute qu'il ya une donnée
particulière est nouvelle sur la
question de la transition écologique
c'est ce qui se passe dans la sphère de
l'ukraine puisqu'en réalité l'une des
décisions qu'on va être obligé de
prendre c'est de réduire notre
dépendance à la russie est donc notre
dépendance au gaz et que à cette
question la transition énergétique et
écologique devient aussi une questions
géostratégiques
au vu des résultats des municipales
quels sont pour vous les vos pronostics
pour les élections européennes
est ce que le ps risque d'être relégué
au clan de 2e 3e 4e parti ne faut pas
faire de pronostics je comprends qu il
une inquiétude pour le ps dans votre
interrogation elle est bien elle est
bien légitime et en même temps ça a un
lien avec notre débat et c'est venu
naturellement il faut remercier de
l'avoir posée à ce moment là au fond
c'est là qu'est la vraie question sur
les sur les choix d'orientation soit ces
élections européennes vont se
transformer dans des élections pour ou
contre l'europe
et là c'est le front national qui va
gagner jusqu au fond je voulais dire ça
c'est un parti dans l'idéologie repose
de quoi sur la peur des gens on a peur
de tout d'abord de l'europe la peur de
l'autre on va se refermer
autant de choses qui comptent très bien
qu'à son domicile et bien sûr il est
bien gentil pour arriver premier être la
première on n'a perdu que des batailles
qu'on m'aime pas je sais des élections
c'est le 25 mai il faudra parler
d'europe
beaucoup parlé d'europe et expliqué
qu'il n'y a pas qu'une seule
il ya aujourd'hui des difficultés à deux
rangs il ya des difficultés de
croissance en europe mais parce que il
ya une commission qui est quand même de
droite parce qu'il ya une majorité de
droite au parlement européen et que la
question de ce que la france puisse
trouver dans une hotte majorité
en europe la possibilité d'accompagner
la reprise et donc d'accompagner le
choix de la croissance que l'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est un enjeu fondamental
chez nous c'est la même chose
ouais c'est pas la même chose d'avoir
monsieur barroso qui dirige l'europe ou
d'avoir martin schulz et c'est ça qu'il
va falloir faire comprendre aux gens il
ya un vrai choix politique tout aussi
important que le choix qu'ils forment
pour les élections municipales parce que
ça concerne leur vie quotidienne pour
les élections françaises
parce que la question européenne s'est
pas envoyé spécial ne vont pas vouloir à
nouveau sanctionné le gouvernement
oman mais pourquoi vous savez je veux
pas interpréter leur vote l'électeur a
toujours raison c'est de notre
responsabilité c'est de la pédagogie
c'est de la politique et ceux que je
viens d'expliquer bien je pense qu'il
faudra l'expliquer par tous parce que
vraiment si gens se mettent à voter pour
ou contre l'europe
alors effectivement imaginer ce qui va
se passer quand même si on a un
parlement européen qui est constituée de
gens majoritairement hostile à l'europe
parce que ce dont on parle ici on parle
du front national enfin tout le monde
sait qu'il se passe à peu près la même
chose dans les penan et dans les autres
pays européens
la montée des nationalismes alors en
mode email l'histoire se répète pas moi
je préfère être prudent dans ses canards
on a un grand projet européen qui
pourrait être ce projet remis en cause
par des gens qui ont une vision qui est
uniquement de faire de l'europe un grand
marché c'est ça le fond d'affaires et
les gens ne veulent les gens ils veulent
l'europe parce que c'est un choix
politique mais ils veulent pas que
l'europe ce soit uniquement en grands
marchés nous non plus mais c'est ce
choix qu'ils feront le 25 mai en votant
et vous aimeriez par exemple que la
commission européenne desserrent l'étau
budgétaire pour ne pas favoriser c'est
votre populisme partout en europe par
exemple ne serait-ce que de modifier les
normes comptables par exemple si on
sortait des déficits des investissements
qui sont des investissements d'avenir
chacun le comprend et il y aurait il y
aurait aucun risque voilà des mesures
mais c'est fait la différence entre la
vision étroite comptable que neuquen
pose aujourd'hui cette commission est ce
que nous demandons avec tous les
socialistes européens
chez les socialistes français ont
l'impression que le feu couve
certains soutiennent mais la marmite est
prête à exploser après dimanche est ce
que vous craignez un grand débat un
grand déballage la curée vous devez être
pu renseigner comme moi j'aime beaucoup
s'exprimant tonalité qui quand même
entre nous sont quand même coutumière du
fait donc mais aussi des élus qui
calculent qu'ils vont voir qu'ils seront
plus réélu dans trois ans qui pendant
quelques beaux mouvements onu mais pas
d'inquiétude pour l'adoption le vote
aura lieu sur le pacte de responsabilité
mais pas d'un coup je suis ministre des
relations avec le parlement je suis pour
le respect des parlementaires le
gouvernement aussi est le premier
ministre est très attaché et si un
travail de conviction de discussion
iloilo rallier ce gouvernement n'est pas
fermé entendre sa majorité est ce que tu
devras être libre c'est sera pas une
marmite il a exposé ce sera une
discussion sur qu'est ce qui s'est passé
comment vous avez ressenti des choses
mais le gouvernement parlera aussi pour
dire on n'entend pas que l'ale deux du
parti dire il faut un peu revoir la
ligne tracée par le président de la
république
on a marre qui vont de plus en plus nous
aurons probablement a probablement ce
débat en même temps tout ça va tanguer -
tout ce que j'ai dit moi je suis
confiant ça va ça va pas tangué ça va
débattre c'est une bonne chose
parti socialiste est un parti est un
parti de débat télé karine rappelait il
ya un instant que les écologistes
finalement ce sont la seule force
politique sortir gagnant 1 des
municipales dans l'attelage
gouvernemental est ce que ça va leur
donner les droits supplémentaires au
sein du gouvernement le mot attelage est
quand même un peu d'ailleurs dans
l'alliance gouvernementale la majorité
présidentielle qu'est-ce qu'ils auront
un troisième ministère est ce qu ils
peuvent prétendre au ministère de
l'environnement tout et les problèmes
quand on vient de parler ce que vous
pensez que la solution à tout ça c'est
de savoir s'il faut une troisième
ministère pour eux j'ai l'impression que
ça compte
franchement j'ai vu plus de respect pour
que vous non mais c'est légitime en même
temps j'espère que ça se présente pas
comme ça c'est le contenu c'est le fond
il va y avoir des débats que y compris
dans le débat avance l'argument oui
c'est pas je dire c'est pas c'est pas
une discussions d'épiciers franchement
si c'est vous aviez raison vous allez
dans le sens de ceux qui se sont
abstenus je pense qu'yves il faut
affirmer une autre idée de la politique
assure bien sûr mais en tous les cas la
composition du gouvernement du futur
gouvernement
si elle est dans tout çà et là et c'est
bien sûr de n'être pas seulement des
journalistes
une gouvernement avec une architecte
convient complètement différente des
pôles des grands pôles de responsabilité
des ministres et des secrétaires d'état
c'est un débat qui est posée pense qu'il
est entre les mains du président je veux
juste devait d'une phrase un faux débat
je lis souvent tu es le grand pays à
côté de chênois 18 ministres et qu'on a
à prendre cette tout ça il faut en 18
min semé il ya 25 secrétaire d'état donc
c'est m'avait gouvernement resserré
n'existe pas vraiment maintenant si le
président peut choisir un autre
périmètre il ya effectivement une
expérience de ces deux années merci car
il n'allait avant d'accueillir perrine
tarneaud je vous propose maintenant
monsieur mise à les voir les efforts que
mène un dévot autres un candidat ps pour
tenter de mobiliser pour le second tour
on est à rosny-sous-bois en
seine-saint-denis la face au maire
sortant ump claude capillon qui est
arrivé largement en tête le candidat ps
donc arpenté quartier populaire où
l'abstention dépasse allègrement les 50%
julien cholin ce soir les troupes
socialistes se lance à la reconquête des
quartiers populaires ici auprès gentil
l'abstention a atteint 55 % en moyenne
pour mobiliser la ligne de l'opposant
numéro un au maire claude capillon est
clair et net
on compte pas dans la résolution de la
politique nationale etc
on dit aux gens que le message est bien
passé au niveau du gouvernement
le message est bien passé il va il y
aura des choses mais on est sur le local
le message est passé le vote sanction a
bien été entendu
alors une fois la porte ouverte place
aux enjeux locaux
les trottoirs les sens interdits les bus
municipaux
tout y passe autant parfois parler du
quartier peut convaincre ça soit la
droite la gauche
pourvu qu'on a quelque chose le temps
pour d'autres la pilule ne passe pas
ancien aller voter non au niveau des
présidentielles pense que françois
hollande a quand même compris le message
et que dans les semaines à venir il va y
avoir vraisemblablement pas des choses
qui vont changer
mais maintenant il s'agit de changer la
vie dans la ville
faire campagne en parlant remaniement
décidément l'impopularité du président
pèse lourd ce qui a été catastrophique
et je le dis sans retenue
c'est la communication faite par par le
gouvernement que la gauche fasse entrer
des gens modestes dans l'impôt qu'ils
n'y étaient pas avant
c'est très très difficile de la faire
comprendre que ça ccc la gauche qui doit
le faire au pied des immeubles une
quinzaine de jeunes interpelle le
candidat aucun accepte d'être filmé ici
c'est la rancoeur qui domine aussi ont
voté françois hollande en 2012
depuis rien n'a changé alors cette fois
et demie rompt pas voter
pourtant dans le local du quartier
peut-être le signe qu'ils attendent
encore quelque chose de la politique
cette petite photo du maire claude
capillon scotché au drapeau du psg il y
aura une quadrangulaire à
rosny-sous-bois dimanche donc avec les
listes de l'ump le maire sortant claude
capillon du ps qu'on a vu philippe
vacquier riz du modem pierre olivier
carell et du front national daniel bour
ce n'est un perrine tarnos et donc et
avec nos ports soient repérés par
michèle méreau question à l'invitation
je les trouvais assez optimiste à
l'heure vous n'avez pas peur du grand
défouloir lors de la rentrée
parlementaire et lors des réunions de
groupe des groupes socialistes ici au
sénat et puis évidemment aussi à
l'assemblée nationale quand même vous
sentez pas cette amertume même cette
panique 1 cherche certains élus locaux
pour peur de perdre leurs sièges parce
que la cité des élections municipales
médaillés
régionales il ya d'autres méthodes qui
vont être importantes sans parler des
sénatoriales le combat politique
il s'arrête pas même après une défaite
on parlait tout à l'heure de 2008
la droite avait connu une défaite
considérables même en 93 c'est la pire
défaite reconnais connu on a regagné en
les élections moi je pense qu'il va y
avoir un débat et c'est bien normal et
en plus on en a besoin puisque les
parlementaires notamment sont ceux qui
sont sur le terrain et donc sont des
interlocuteurs privilégiés pour le
gouvernement que sur le résultat des
élections municipales il va aussi sur le
cap fixé par ce gouvernement où le
prochain gouvernement
oui mais en public oui oui qui a été élu
sur cette ligne là et on va
oui mais il ya des explications à donner
je me rendais votre rêve reportage notre
candidat dit on ne comprend pas pourquoi
des personnes ayant de faibles revenus
sont rentrés dans l'impôt pourquoi en
assumant sa question qui quand on écoute
les lots du matin oui et alors c'est
quand même assez simple de répondre
qu'il ya deux mesures qui sont à
l'origine de ça qu'on n'a pas pu
remettre en cause qu'ils sont sains
le gel du barème de l'impôt pour deux
ans quand on est arrivé au pouvoir alors
que les caisses étaient vides et la
suppression de la demi-part pour les
veuves qui a été prise avant et donc
quand on est arrivés du gouvernement
précédent l'armée quand vous arrivez que
c'est entre assumer ce qu'on a décidé
nous et assumer les conséquences de ce
qu'ont fait les autres et quand même une
marge
donc on peut répondre ça aux gens
d'autant plus qu'ils peuvent nous dire à
ce moment là oui mais vous aviez call
remettre en cause sauf que non seulement
il l'avait fait mais qu'en plus les
caisses étaient vides
voilà donc ça c'est toute la difficulté
de ce à quoi on a été confronté mais je
souhaitais peut l'expliquer assez
simplement vengeance est-ce que vous
même vous avez pris un coup sur la tête
dans votre département des landes
moitié-moitié gens venir il y en avait
un espoir de reconquête sur la ville
chef-lieu ça s'est pas bien passé mais
en même temps il a été élu dès le
premier tour
oui tu t'étais sortant vit à une seule
liste de droite a été élu au premier
tour
en même temps la ville de dax qu'on a
appris que le deuxième hic qu'on a pris
en 2008
depuis on pouvait normalement apparaître
comme étant en danger notre candidat a
fait un excellent score je pense qu'il
serait ce que vous avez été vous même
surpris par l'ampleur de ce vote
sanction dimanche soir que personne
n'avait vraiment venir pas les sondés en
tous les cas n'est vous le responsable
c'est l'ampleur de l'abstention
l'abstention c'est l'ampleur de
l'abstention qui c'est à dire ce qu'on
appelle le le différentiel l'abstention
c'est à dire l'électorat de droite est
forcément mobilisés depuis 2012 il
attend que ça va venir voter contre tout
ce qui ressemble de près ou de loin à la
gauche donc il l'a fait il ya rien à
dire et l'électorat de gauche mais comme
ça s'était passé dans toutes les
élections intermédiaires sauf que ça a
été probablement un peu plus un peu plus
un peu plus marqué voilà c'est tout mais
c'est pas non plus une surprise totale
on en pleure oui les européennes on a
parlé tout à l'heure les élections
sénatoriales
ici on a vu au sénat tout le monde
sortir à nouveau sa calculette et
beaucoup d'où jean pierre raffarin
ancien premier ministre qui était hier
sur un plateau le dise maintenant à
droite et une possibilité d'alternance
en septembre 2014
cela vous y croyez il faut partout où il
ya des élections il ya toujours une
possibilité d'alternance je ne vais pas
faire des pronostics d'abord moi je
t'invite tout le monde peut-être
attendre le deuxième tour il me surprend
beaucoup c'est que la droite triomphe
comme si on distribuait les prix a
ajouté monsieur raffarin vient ici et
tire
il tire pour les élections sénatoriales
des conséquences à partir du premier
tour des élections municipales suffisant
probablement quand même aux jeux
olympiques on n'aime pas les médailles à
la mi-temps gentil raffarin on va
l'écouter aussi il a eu des mots assez
durs concernant le gouvernement sur
l'attitude du gouvernement vis-à-vis du
sénat écouter l'ancien premier ministre
ce qu'il faudra le moment venu c'est
qu'on ait une stratégie au fonds pour
sauver le sénat pour rénover sénat pour
changer le sénat sont des religieux là
et mais bien sûr qu'on voit bien que le
sénat est en cause aujourd'hui le
gouvernement le marginalise on à l'ap
cependant le sentiment qu est une forme
d'indécence et surtout d'amérique mais
ça c'est pas de notre fait
c'est parce qu'il ya eu un partage de
pouvoir qui n'a pas correspondu à un
partage du projet votre réaction est en
campagne électorale pour la présidence
du sénat avant de s'occuper de la gauche
construit faudra d'abord qui s'occupe de
ses propres amis alors l'argument qui
consiste à dire ce gouvernement est
hostile au sénat dans mais très
honnêtement moi je suis là toutes les
semaines il ya des bons débats au sénat
disent qu'il est dans la suite de son
intervention assez intéressante et dès
qu'il ya eu un partage du pouvoir et
senna mais il n'ya pas partage du projet
politique entre vous les socialistes les
verts ou encore les communistes c'est
surtout pas vous n'allez pas découvrir
qu'on n'a pas de majorité ici au sénat
donc c'est une réalité qui explique que
certain nombre de textes ont été
refusées mais il ya procès à faire à
personne ni à la droite je fait son
travail pas au groupe communiste et
fidèle à ses convictions et donc ensuite
la procédure se déroule mais vous savez
des lois très importantes sont passés en
premier au sénat ça pas toujours été
facile à l'assemblée quand j'ai annoncé
que la loi de programmation militaire
qui est important pour des
parlementaires elle serait d'abord
examiné au sénat l'assemblée on m'a dit
à l'inversé si on m'a dit quand même
c'est donner au sénat un rôle important
non nous sommes pour le bicamérisme très
clairement nous ne sommes pas favorables
à la spécialisation du sénat comme étant
la chambre des collectivités locales
pour être très clair et nous
reconnaissons sa spécificité
donc ça c'est la réponse à jean pierre
raffarin sur le calendrier des semaines
le calendrier parlementaire est ce que
dans ce calendrier bien on va voir
l'urgence économique sociale marquée
dans l'est dans les semaines à venir
par exemple sur le pack de
responsabilité est ce que ça va venir à
l'assemblée nationale vers le 15 16
avril vote de confiance comme ça l'est
plus comme c'est annoncé bon merci de
pas avoir précisé l'heure en plus
puisque ce jeu sera pas dans le courant
du mois d'avril je ne sais pas
exactement à quelle date le président
vous avez vous avez vous avez la réponse
je sais pas nickel journée mais ce sera
là donc c'est ça n'a pas de sens donc y
aura une déclaration à l'assemblée avec
l'engagement de responsabilité sur fond
de ma marque 49 1 de la constitution
est-ce qu'il faut mettre au rancart
toutes les réformes sociétales et son
concernant l'économie qu'elle devient le
sur jeu posé la question mais sûr que
non c'est pas là aussi sont des faux
débat pourquoi faudrait-il faire des
choix entre le social et le sociétal
dans une politique une politique c'est
un tout il ya des textes qui lui c'est
le résultat du premier tour des
municipales et bien peut-être que le
maillage pour tous a finalement laissé
des traces dans l'opinion sa à mobiliser
l'électorat de droite
c'est clair enfin l'électorat de droite
je veux pas être respectifs
l'électorat de droite hostiles à aso à
ce texte
mais peut-être à l'équipe de l'électorat
de gauche qui est favorable justement
considère qu'il fallait qu'il se
mobilise aussi pour soutenir ces
réformes important donc au parlement
d'ici cet été il y aura des débats sur
la prostitution sur la fin de vie sur la
prostitution c'est prévu sur la fin de
vie c'est pas prévu avant la fin de
l'été pour répondre pas voilà des
vacances pour répondre très précisément
président avait dit quoi le monde
déposera un texte que ce qu'on attend un
certain nombre d'avis avant la fin de
l'année de 2014 une un mot peut-être sur
la visite en france du président chinois
est ce qu'au nom des intérêts
économiques il faut mettre de côté
toutes les questions sur les droits de
l'homme ça pas les mettre de côté
je pense que quand le président de la
république et de télé
et là pendant la visite écoutez vous
savez très bien comment ça se passe
c'est sans forcément abordé dans des
discussions qui sont des discussions de
chefs d'état chefs d'état mais elles
n'ont pas la france n'a pas décidé de ne
pas reconnaître ce qui est l'importance
de ses relations économiques avec la
chine voit la télé vers la mer sans
pression ils ont écrit à françois
hollande ils veulent que l'ambassadrice
de france en chine se rendre au tibet
oui mais on connaît leur position
là-dessus mais je veux dire une espèce
de monde idéal dans lequel on aurait des
rapports économiques et diplomatiques
qu'avec des gens parfaits j'aspire je le
souhaite ça veut pas dire ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut renoncer au débat non on
sait très bien en veille que c'est la
realpolitik en même temps la france est
porteur et on le sait très bien et ce
ceux qui se battent dans ces pays pour
conquérir des droits ils veulent qu'on
continue à avoir des relations avec leur
pays parce que c'est là qu'on est le
plus efficace et que ceux qui s'ils ont
une position radicale se trouve
justement parce que si on n'a plus de
rapport alors la place et est nette et
ils ont besoin effectivement que l'on
sonné reconnu des interlocuteurs par
leur pays ne serait ce que pour faire
améliorer les choses sans tous les cas
ce qui prime aujourd'hui ce sont les
accords commerciaux il y en a une
cinquantaine qui ont été signés à
l'elysée pour un total de 18 milliards
d'euros on parlera du tibet après c'est
pas l'un ou l'autre des droits de
l'homme c'est pas l'un ou l'autre
j'accepte part je trouve que votre
observation années passant par l'or
c'est pas l'un ou l'autre il peut être
question des deux choses il ya eu des
positions qui ont été données par la
france en matière politique tend vers
franchement franchement si un pays qui
est au rendez vous aujourd'hui pour
défendre la démocratie y compris quand
tous les autres s'échappe parfois c'est
la france on est allé au mali il y avait
un massacre en centrafrique au nlhe et a
laissé des soldats français je le rends
hommage et c'est la décision du
président de la république alors il
paraît qu'on peut parler effectivement
de liberté aux présidentielles mais il
est bon de le prévenir par avance donc
c'est ce qui a dû être préparé en
coulisses on verra ça en tous les cas
merci ça s'appelle de la diplômée ça
s'appelle de la diplomatie merci c'est
parfois efficace et ctv
rouleau sur les personnes toi merci
beaucoup alain vidalis d'avoir été avec
nous bonsoir à tous et à très vite